con una altura de 138 metros es la más
alta y también la más nueva torre de la
catedral de la sagrada familia y está
dedicada a la virgen maría pero una vez
terminada la obra será la segunda más
alta de un total de 18 planeadas por el
arquitecto catalán antoni gaudí cuyo
trabajo en la basílica comenzó en 1883 y
casi 140 años después todavía su
construcción está en progreso y jordi
faulí es ahora el séptimo arquitecto que
supervisa su finalización
pero cuando yo llegué de estas columnas
que viene aquí de atrás sólo estaban
construidas tres del lado
poniente y solo los primeros
10 metros a pesar de los avances la
junta de construcción de la catedral ha
abandonado el objetivo de completarla
para 2026 año del centenario de la
muerte de gaudí la pandemia de
coronavirus aceptó un duro golpe a los
ingresos del monumento con las puertas
cerradas durante casi un año se vio
privada de la venta de entradas una de
las principales fuentes de
financiamiento de las obras en curso
e intuimos que para las obras
esto es casi un año sin recibir
visitantes por tanto aunque haya un
había un hubo buenos donativos pero sin
tener la aportación
importante de los visitantes y en ese
momento él junto con su toro tomó una
decisión como otras que ha tomado
durante todo su historia en momentos
clave
[Música]
tenemos unos unos euros ahorrados pues
con esto vamos a acabar una torre
con una gran cantidad de trabajo por
hacer es posible que foul y no pueda
supervisar la finalización de la sagrada
familia pero el hombre de 62 años su
equipo de arquitectos y constructores
están decididos a dar vida a la visión
de gaudí